ou
contraint forcé mais pas résigné c'est
avec humour que les serveurs du café
jules répondent aux obligations de
contrôle du pass sanitaires je vais
contrôler vos pas s'il vous plaît avant
la rentrée
oui on fait la police
en l'occurrence le shérif le gérant
souhaite dénoncer cette tâche inadapté
au travail de serveurs le stock de
déguisement est plein mais sa colère et
froide nous faisons partie des pouvoirs
régaliens de l'état c'est à dire nous
avons à
la fonction de police nous contrôlons la
population afin qu'il puisse rentrer
dans nos établissements autant apporter
une petite touche d'humour voilà pour
juste montrer que voilà qu'on n'est pas
spécialement pour ce n'est pas notre
métier c'est pas notre rôle de contrôle
et de contrôler les gens chapeau de
chérif uniformes de policiers menottes
aux casquettes du fbi à toute l'équipe
s'est prêté au jeu pour faire passer le
message
si les déguisements n'atténueront
probablement pas l'amertume du
restaurateur la clientèle le soutien et
s'amuse de ce clin d'oeil
c'est sympa c'est bien c'est si agréable
celles accueillant
puis tout ça avec une dérision vraiment
voilà c'est pour éviter ce manque que
quelques les gens soient agressés en
demandant le poste sanitaire et non je
veux ça s'est vraiment bien
c'est très bien d'avoir retrouvé ce truc
là quoi j'apprécie énormément leur
dérision
le les cas effectivement leur a donné un
rôle qui n'est pas le leur
je pense qu'ils sont pas mal occupé la
joue autour de moi ça se beaucoup
d'effervescence leur ajouter une petite
tache en plus bas est ce que ça valait
le coup peut-être pas
la mise en place du pass sanitaire
impacter fortement le chiffre d'affaires
de l'établissement
avec -30% le premier jour et -15 le
second alors que la saison estivale bat
son plein la clientèle âgée de 20 à 30
ans habituée à venir consommer en fin de
soirée a quant à elle déserté les cafés